this question don't you life constantly
I never told the truth I've seen your
videos you constantly lie one point when
you talk about the the Muslim helping
out in the recent attacks he said then
smoke about what Muslims did it wasn't
just Muslims those Hindus Sikhs
non-believers what I like doing the same
thing but you never spoke about them you
just focused on the Muslims
you
so I would not give you any time to
speak to me very valid phones if I've
lied about that then obviously you're
right
however in lied about it you've lied
about it you claim I have so you know
it's fact it's on your video would you
allow me to speak okay now as well as
question you know when terrorist attacks
happen and you come and say this is
Islam the green phone tower and the
Muslim community was doing a lot is this
Islam - are you here to make videos and
propagate that and say is this Islam
cheese Lamas there is this it's not
you're not gonna fool me is this Islam -
we're not gonna for me oh this is nice
let's read surah 9 io 5 when Islam does
an act of terrorism this is Islam when
was him do something good why you
bringing a village into it thank you
very much and I talked enough goodbye
let's move on let's move on now slowly
let's move on come on calm calm calm hi
hi how you doing okay thank you
you know Islam is on fire or people from
other faiths you finish my question you
wanna ask you my question I came to ask
what happened in grapefruit ours the
Muslims were doing their job helping
humanity is this form Islam is Muslims
[Laughter]
tell me I can show you the Bible Way
tells me hello can I reach your question
does you said visit mention the word
love yes you did I said show me in the
'quran show me a verse in the Quran yeah
that direct you as a Muslim to be cut no
telling me hold on why not me or us as a
Christian excuse me - no question Allah
does not forbid you as regardless as
regards those who did not fight you
wanna count on your faith
I'll carry on no no Ali honey you're
gonna have your home he was out you be
careful honey why you do good to them
when bad news live then surely Allah
knows all it's injustice letting up now
the reason why I did this today's these
guys come here every day whenever today
let's move on
come come we're gonna find it we're
gonna find another when I find another
hate preacher here we're gonna have a
new Quran
come come what we're doing today is
every time I cherish that that happens
we got hate preachers community that's
Islam does it start decis Lamia so I
came today but I came today and I was
that look what happened in the Grand
Hotel on the community nor Muslims do it
no it's humanity Muslims or non-muslims
but when Muslims do it now why'd you
have to bring the religion into it this
is the hypocrisy we went to two of them
and asked a simple question yeah big o
ry bringing the religion to it why you
bring the Marvel engine true and
terrorist attacks happening so we're
just taking a little stroll around the
park you can join us we just want some
answers yeah just just follow us in
shalyah you can follow me on Facebook is
one if you like there's another one
there's another one there's another one
do you mind me asking her a question
okay hi I'm Adam we just wondered you
know the recent finger man in green
photos you know the fire happened
religion Muslim help those people in the
Grateful Tower and the Muslim community
you will be stopped so as we can see
guy's a pro proceed these are hate
preachers these are a preacher and
another one when when when was when was
it do something good they don't want to
know when the terrorist attack happens
Islamist and stop Isis the face show me
where
Hey
okay okay
men women children babies and donkeys we
need okay so far where's that maybe one
okay I hide it okay as far as we know
every time most of you and your friends
come here when a terrorist attack
happens you say Islam Islam Islam Islam
a grand fruit our block what a great
photographer give me some space a tower
was burning and there was a lady outside
saying if it wasn't for the Muslims
coming from Brea and they did knock on
our door many people have died is this
the teaching of Islam I don't know you
don't know so when the terrorist attack
happens you know the what about your
Quran says it okay so my Quran also says
in quran chapter 16 verse 8 verse 8 i
love does not forbid you as robots to
those who did not fight you in the
kernel deeply maybe if you did it so you
tell me because i'm a muslim you don't
fight and you don't kick me out my house
Allah does not forbid you from being
bunch of them and be
what happened in the okay
there were everyone that were helping in
the mosque in the church in the
community who write a mission my mouth I
don't know what you said look what
Muslims do no that's what you say oh
okay once the people can go watch on his
channel okay you said wouldn't do this
little shower will change
yeah well mousse mr. gently there was a
Hindu atheist yes
nobody is a non-believer okay okay good
clean the mosque in the church in the
community walk he's right but your
points are not only the Muslims why but
why me tell you why BBC news is that
well Fox does a nice that's what you're
doing on your channel a lead our there's
a channel of lies what you do okay thank
you he mentions a very good point here
he said Ali the Barry I'll give you
another about here okay I will one thing
that he mentioned one thing he came I
physically prepared man when you go
Tommy's fantasy and here visualize you
after you're prepared with a trying to
be prepared good point he said there was
Christians there was Hindus there was
non-believers one second my point the
reason why I mentioned Muslims is not
because Muslims do something special
about the other stuff you won't you
don't know I didn't if you watch my
video you did and what you did I
I listen to you listen to me if you go
to my video I clearly said there was
people from all backgrounds see how
nobody news tied up with a video about
12 minutes 12 minutes yes ham ham ham
relevant irrelevant console are you made
this are you my producer you can't say
welcome put and I ever finished now my
question is how many Muslim okay and
history in history everywhere
you better have something happening but
the Muslim terrorists why'd you cover it
okay religion heroism has no religion
hold on terrorism has no religion in the
charisma hydrogen in the Quran these
Muslims Arizona religion can answer
question these mooses show me a
one-piece in the Durrani okay
can I finish
okay